welche Schnitzel müssen nicht immer aus
der Packung kommen wir machen
blumenkohlschnitzel wir brauchen einen
Blumenkohl außerdem alles für eine
panierstraße das heißt mehl Eier und
Paniermehl wir schneiden einen
fingerbreites Stück aus der Mitte
unseres Blumenkohls Finger ich habe uns
zwei schöne Steaks aus der Mitte
geschnitten und die koche ich jetzt ein
bisschen vor einfach nur dass sie weich
werden der Blumenkohl ist vorgegart
Tropfen ihn ab und danken Steffen
Henssler dass wir uns dieses Rezept
vorgestellt hat jetzt legen wir unseren
Blumenkohl in Mehl wegen ihnen ein
bisschen ihr Salzen unser Ei und geben
etwas Pfeffer dran und unser Blumenkohl
Steak sind von beiden Seiten ordentlich
mit Eimasse bedecken und zu guter Letzt
ins Pankow Mehl mit dem wir es rundum
bedecken und ab in die Pfanne mit heißem
Öl es ist irgendwo zwischen Braten und
Frittieren ich weiß es selbst nicht
genau nach wenigen Minuten sieht das
ganze so aus eine wunderschöne goldgelbe
Farbe und eine wunderschöne Kruste und
abtropfen lassen
oh Mama mir wunderschönes Medium
boah